منذ اعلان روسيا عدم التمديد العمل باتفاق
نقل الحبوب اصبح ساحه لتبادل الضربات
والاستهداف بين روسيا واوكرانيا حيث تعرض
ميناء اوديسا اسماعيل ومنشاه تخزين للحبوب
اكثر من مره لهجمات روسيه بالمسيره
والصواريخ دمرت الاف الاطنان من الحبوب
وفق الروايه الاوكرانيه ومنشاه عسكريه وفق
روايه موسكو حرب السفن جعلت روسيا تعلن
قبل ايام تنفيذ قواتها انزالا على السفينه
شحن متجهه الى ميناء اسماعيل الاوكراني
وقالت ان سفينه الشحن تابعت مسارها نحو
الميناء بعد انتهاء التفتيش تلك حرب
استعراض في عرض البحر توازيها اخرى في
الموانئ هجومان جديدان بطائرات مسيره من
نوع شاهد قالت الاداره العسكريه الاقليميه
في اوديسا انهما استهدفت البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ والحبوب اذ سمع ذوي انفجارات قويه
في محيط ميناء اسماعيل على نهر الدانوب
مجددا حاول الع
انظمه الصاروخيه تبدا من صواريخ نبتون
الاوكرانيه وتنتهي بالانظمه الغربيه مثل
نظام هاربون الذي قدمه لنا الشركاء تغطي
هذه المنظومات 100 ميل من سواحلنا اما
بالنسبه للمناطق التي تقع خارج هذا النطاق
فلدينا وسائلنا الخاصه لاستكمال وتنفيذ كل
المهام الموكله لنا وقد يكون ضمن هذه
الوسائل الخاصه ما كشفته اداره امن الدوله
الاوكرانيه عما قالت انها مسيره بحريه
مصنعه محليا هجمت خلال الفتره الماضيه جسر
القرن وسفينه هجوميه برمائيه روسيه مناقله
للنفط وقد لا تجد كياف نفسها وحيده في
مواجهه تاردات الروسيه فقد نقلت عن
مسؤولين قولهم ان واشنطن تجري محادثات مع
تركيا واوكرانيا ودول اخرى لانشاء طرق
بديله لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
واشارت الى ان الخطه تهدف لضمان شحن
الحبوب عبر نهر الدانوب والبحر الاسود الى
الموانئ القريبه من رومانيا لتشحن الى
وجهات اخرى ورفع قدره اوكرانيا على
التصدير الى اربعه ملايين طن من الحبوب
شهريا بحلول اكتوبر لكن واشنطن جورنال
تدرس كل الخيارات بما فيها العسكريه
لحمايه السفن الحبوب القادمه من والى هذه
الموانئ